well there is outrage tonight on social
media after mountain lion was shot and
killed in a west las vegas neighborhood
now it had been found in somebody's
backyard but others have also shared
images of that big cat roaming in their
communities madison kimbrough joining us
now live with reaction to this tonight
denise many people on our eight news now
facebook page upset over the killing of
this wild cat many wondering why it
couldn't have been tranquilized
they shot the mountain lion and they
we look and there's just a mountain lion
there
you can see the blood of it and there's
like cops all in our backyard a scary
situation monday as residents were told
to stay indoors as a mountain lion was
on the loose in their spring mountain
neighborhood metro police along with
envy wildlife arriving on scene taking a
few hours to capture the wild cat they
seen them jump the wall and go into our
backyard and they said our pet bull was
barking and they think our pet bulls
scared
the mountain lion up the tree the
mountain lion never harmed anyone but
was eventually killed in that backyard
many taking to social media to share
their concerns as to why the wild cat
had to be killed and why not
tranquilized comments like this one from
facebook user gay ann jones saying what
happened to catch and release and
another one from vivian clayson saying
quote absolutely no reason to kill this
animal facebook user kenneth wittern had
this to say we're invading on their
habitat not the other way around there
have been 10 sightings of mountain lions
reported across the valley in the past
two years specifically on the west side
of town
and as of now it's still unclear as to
why the mountain lion was killed as
neighbors shared that the cat never
approached anyone now we've reached out
to the department of wildlife for more
information but have yet to hear back in
studio madison kimbrough live local now
madison thank you